c'est le début de notre 51e saison sur
les ondes de radio canada et c'est
devenu un peu une tradition on commence
par un retour sur l'été qui s'achève
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au cours des
derniers mois qu'est ce qui a retenu
l'attention en forêt dans les champs en
mer en voici un résumé
de l'été 2021 on retiendra certainement
deux mots chaleur et incendies
quatre provinces deux territoires de
l'ouest du pays sont maintenant
prisonnier de ce don de chaleur extrême
conséquences des changements climatiques
au moins 233 morts subites ont été
signalés depuis quatre jours
fin juin le village de little en
colombie-britannique fracasse pendant
trois jours d'affilée des records
canadiens de température culminant à
49,6 degrés celsius le lendemain le
village est la proie des flammes
regardez les images le village a été
réduit en cendres en quelques heures à
peine
tout au long de l'été des centaines de
brasiers ont été recensés dans la
province le gouvernement a déclaré
l'état d'urgence en juillet et a appelé
en renfort des pompiers tout si loin que
de l'australie
autre conséquence de cette canicule
inédite les côtes de la
colombie-britannique se sont transformés
en cimetières de crustacés et d'algues
et c'est vrai que c'est comme attraper
des coups de soleil à répétition il
faudra voir quel sera l'impact à long
terme
de l'autre côté des rocheuses aussi la
chaleur a fait des ravages dans les
champs cette fois ci
après une année 2009 un sèche et un
hiver sans grand couvert de neige le
manque d'eau étaient criants dès le mois
de mai
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a rien ici pour appuyer le
développement des grains dit il entre
ses doigts la terre noire cool comme du
sable le fermier doit planter ses
semences plus profondément que
d'habitude pour espérer les voir pousser
la pluie s'est fait attendre tout l'été
la sécheresse de 2021 pourrait être la
pire de l'histoire canadienne une
catastrophe pour les fermiers et les
éleveurs de bétail à bien des endroits
l'eau pour les bêtes se fait rare tout
comme le fourrage
en juillet et en août les ans quand on
tournait à plein régime pour les
25 à 50 % de notre cheptel va
disparaître explique cet enchanteur et
comme si ce n'était pas assez le temps
chaud et sec a favorisé la prolifération
des sauterelles qui ont dévoré les
maigres récoltes
n'ya qu'une petite poignée de lentilles
ici des sauterelles ont presque tous
mangé la production est réduite à
presque rien les trois provinces des
prairies et le gouvernement fédéral ont
annoncé de l'aide d'urgence pour les
agriculteurs alors que plusieurs sont à
bout de souffle des fermiers qu'ils sont
déprimés et extrêmement stressant
sionneau là on veut un point que nature
pour
les gens humaine
cela fait maintenant des décennies que
les scientifiques partout à travers le
monde tire la sonnette d'alarmé
le mois de juillet a été le mois le plus
chaud jamais enregistré sur terre et les
exemples de dérèglements climatiques
n'ont pas manqué cet été
dans l'est du pays le printemps aussi
étés chauds et secs et pour certains la
promesse d'une belle saison s'est
envolée à la fin mais
[Musique]
les conditions étaient presque toutes
rassemblées ce printemps pour permettre
aux producteurs de procéder à la
plantation de leur culture près de deux
semaines plus tôt que les années
précédentes mais l'objet de la nuit
dernière a joué un vilain tour à
certains agriculteurs particulièrement
dans le haut du lac-saint-jean
normalement qui sonne plus tôt mais
les
pistes
c'est la première fois que ça arrive
si tu ta définition
qu un moule à isna
si certains champs de soya notamment ont
dû être remis les vignes ont aussi été
touchés par le gel tout comme les plants
de bleuets dont la floraison était déjà
bien entamée voici jusqu'à la couleur en
temps réel de dubai toit du bras ou le
brun a probablement eu du mal ce mal
c'est le froid le mercure a chuté
jusqu'à moins quatre degrés celsius par
endroit et ça devrait perdurer ce
week-end selon les prévisions
météorologiques d'environnement canada
les impacts sont énormes on s'attend à
récolter 50 % moins de bleuets au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean par rapport à
l'an dernier et dans certaines
communautés autochtones de l'abitibi et
du nord de l'ontario on rapporte qu'il
n'y avait aucun bleuets sauvages
accueillir du jamais vu le gel a même
causé des dommages beaucoup plus au sud
certains producteurs s'inquiètent
d'ailleurs de l'inaction des
gouvernements dans la crise climatique
de des gens qui va prendre des décisions
qui sont prises où on leur le sonotone
et les deux mais nanterre outre les
aléas de la météo les conditions de
logement de certains travailleurs du
secteur agroalimentaire ont aussi fait
la manchette
l'un des plus grands producteurs de
fruits et légumes du québec les
productions horticoles demers s'est
retrouvé au coeur de la tourmente
lorsqu'une enquête de radio canada a
révélé les conditions dans lesquelles
vivaient certains de ses employés près
de drummondville
alertés par plusieurs travailleurs
étrangers nous nous rendons sur place et
nous montre la présence de moisissures
sur les murs leur chambre où ils
s'entassent et c'est le peu de rangement
cet homme dans avec sa valise les
installations vétustes
nous sommes dans un pays développé je ne
pensais pas que c'était possible
[Musique]
cet été les productions horticoles
demers ont entrepris des rénovations
importantes dans l'ancien hôtel où
logent les travailleurs c'est surtout la
notion d' avance la scion qui est
compliqué dans une d'ensemble la section
qu'il était aux prises avec de la
moisissure est toujours en travaux soit
c'est un modèle de chant donc il y avait
ici avec quatre personnes maintenant il
y en a deux
essentiellement on a fait disparaître
tous les listes l'ellipse propositions
sont acceptées le dal dans la
réglementation actuelle et on était
conforme à cette réglementation là mais
maintenant on va au delà de ça pour
loger tous ces travailleurs l'entreprise
a dû doubler la surface de ces
habitations elle a donc fait
l'acquisition en juillet d'une ancienne
résidence pour personnes âgées où
presque chaque chambre a sa propre salle
de bain on a manqué de vigilance puis
l'eau sont le bien à brive puis envoie
être extrêmement prudent selon les
défenseurs des droits des travailleurs
étrangers il est urgent de revoir les
normes entourant le logement ils sont
pas assez sévères par exemple il ya une
douche pour dix travailleurs on sait
bien qu'une douche pour dit ce n'est pas
assez entre les lits peut avoir 40 102
cm de distance c'est très peu mais c'est
la coga notation qui dit ça les
productions horticoles demers accueille
des travailleurs étrangers depuis 25 ans
et ses normes n'ont jamais changé je
pense qu'à travers l'événement que moi
que nous avons vécu chez nous il y eut
haussé réglementation le qui était
peut-être pas adéquat et mises à jour
dans les camp forestier et minier où
logent majoritairement de la main
d'oeuvre locale les lits superposés sont
interdits depuis 1981
le gouvernement fédéral se penche
actuellement sur une révision de
l'ensemble des normes entourant le
logement des travailleurs agricoles
qui a aussi retenu l'attention au cours
des derniers mois ce sont deux conflits
de travail dans des abattoirs qui ont
affecté tant les humains que les animaux
celui chez exceldor a duré plus d'un
mois et a entraîné l'euthanasie de près
d'un million et demi d'oiseaux celui
chez olymel a pris fin au bout de quatre
mois 180 milles port était en attente
d'une place à l'abattoir dans les deux
cas la fermeture d'un seul abattoir à
déstabiliser toute une industrie nous
reviendrons sur le sujet au cours de la
saison
[Musique]
autre dossier à l'avant scène cet été
les résidus de pesticides dans les
aliments
en juillet on apprend que santé canada
souhaite doubler la teneur maximale de
glyphosate dans les points et les
lentilles et la voir tripler dans le cas
des haricots et des pois chiches quant
au canada après que c'est la
multinationale bailleur qu'a provoquée
la révision des normes sur les
pesticides entamée par ottawa le
glyphosate est l'ingrédient actif du
roundup commercialisé autrefois par
monsanto désormais propriété de bayer
c'est l'herbicide le plus vendu dans le
monde
après le glyphosate dans les
légumineuses santé canada propose
maintenant de faire grimper les seuils
de résidus de pesticides dans les
bleuets sauvages et les framboises cette
fois plus de résidus de certains
pesticides dans les framboises trois
fois plus dans les bleuets
c'est ce que propose santé canada dans
le cadre de deux consultations publiques
dans ce cas si c'était entre autres le
géant de l'agrochimie syngenta qui avait
demandé une hausse des seuils jugés sans
danger pour la population selon santé
canada il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il
l'a l'agent de réglementation de la
lutte antiparasitaire se base largement
sur des études réalisées par les
fabricants par l'industrie des
pesticides donc pour moi il ya un
problème éthique majeur reste au niveau
là début ou ottawa a finalement fait
volte-face et annoncé l'abandon des
projets de hausse de limites de résidus
de pesticides
[Musique]
et pour terminer sur une bonne nouvelle
à shippagan au nouveau brunswick un
nouveau bateau permettra d'agir plus
rapidement pour des ans pétri les
baleines noire dans le golfe du saint
laurent cette espèce en péril compte
moins de 400 individus l'équipe de
sauvetage est une initiative d'un groupe
de pêcheurs acadien
on
puis au final ce sont des êtres par la
mer c'est probablement les quatre les
duos syrie pour naviguer pour accrocher
les baleines 9